hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play watch yes
yep okay this is another indie game from
game jolt another pixelated style I have
a feeling that they all use a similar
engine I'm just not sure what it is I
think it might be game creator I'm not
sure but either way they've been pretty
good so far and this one's highly rated
so let's give this a try start
intervention and well let's start at the
beginning it would be silly to start at
the end okay the beginning
click R to restart level control the
Crouch Mouse to look a desk WD to move I
move fast okay so I move kind of Wankel
e but forward very quickly alright so
let's see here um these computers don't
look like they work I'm just gonna say
that right now
oh whoa is that what well I do a diving
lunging Crouch wow so the next Call of
Duty what are you what are you ha boom
boom boom dramatic the 50s horror movie
music do I have a flashlight cuz it's
dark in there
alright alright then don't know what's
going on but that's a good thing oh
there's a flashlight hello
bring your daughter to work day Susan
wouldn't interact with the others I
think she may have a cold after work I
might take her to the doctor hey I mean
this is my daughter
oh this isn't a good I hear that don't f
with me man but that you're running you
will fall over water coolers what what
what does that even mean
a [ __ ] or water cult what does that
even mean I'm in an office I'm sorry to
crouch okay that's weird
crouch ah what is going on here
Adam oh my daughter is an evil demon
makes sense all these horror games
eventually got to me ah oh that's a
chair
not a horrifying daughter to chair pose
ex post ex you mean post my ex yeah
makes sense I just climbed over that
okay my co-workers were feeling uneasy
but wouldn't tell me why many of them
decided to take a leave even Adam
wouldn't tell me what was going on that
my daughter was an evil demonic entity
from another world probably probably
where are you sweetie honey ah run from
wine run from Wyatt tell me what I'm
running from what the hell are we
running from I don't know ah
bomb bomb bomb bomb
stop that is that noise again there
another key or something I don't like
these dark hallways wait what's that
noise where's it coming from
roll a bell well man that is an annoying
noise for a key ah water coolers stop it
Crouch I'm in a loop I'm stuck in a loop
okay god I broke the game again I broke
the game again you gotta be no okay
there we go
Jesus that's a stupid mechanic I mean
it's supposed to be like if you're
running away you got a oh no I don't
even know what it's supposed to be I
can't go through there I know I run I
fall as yeah I'll I'm bad at games I'm
bad at games and stuff here we go
another door I can get through here
unless this is whoa oh no I thought that
was an arrow okay nevermind
aah run run gah bah what the hell are
you doing that was stupid
Joe come here I'll getcha roar I'm a
monster
burp bring bear boy was okay that's the
same one before
what what the hell what the hell
Crouch rude stupid key noise I was
trying to run in that account gamblin
Ikuko I'm trying I'm trying Ryu good no
actually I'm not I'm not doing good at
all this game is so I see ok anyway
this actually is pretty interesting I
mean obviously what's going on is a guy
makes a game and this is actually
something that I admire in terms of game
making um well I just what did I just do
I've vaulted over something don't know
what ok anyway um they make a game but
they don't dedicate um they don't
dedicate immediately to aah run
crouching and run I'm running
that's my daughter that is really weird
how do my daughter become all my I saw
that key noise again
because they just work Oh anyway I was
saying that the game maker prioritizes
on getting the game itself done and
working very basic mechanics just to get
something to try for people to do and
that's admirable in a lot of ways
because because then you have something
that people can enjoy without you know
without worrying too much about whether
the art is good or whether it's like a
perfect system yet you can you can have
something that people can try running
crouching running as fast as I can
Crouch and then people have something
that you can try and then intermission
oh okay I'm outside now and then people
can tell you what it is I mean uh it's
different than like the game I played
earlier today which had a lot of work in
you in terms of art but that wasn't like
the whole game wasn't done oh yeah I
don't know what I'm talking about
ignore me I'm just blabbering now okay
so I'm outside now in a city don't know
how I got here but I am looking for keys
there are invisible walls at every turn
so uh what what am I doing here what am
i doing what's going on II OH
okay climb over that hey hey you I got a
bone to pick with you you've been uh uh
don't you run away from me I am your
father
and you you need to obey me yeah bad
daughters what can you do what can you
do oh maybe I'm going into the woods now
okay
is something wrong with Susan don't turn
around us Oh what what a hand ha ha ha
aha good I hear a key
don't turn around but how am I supposed
to not turn around hahahahahaha
that was good that was really good
I mean well oh god damn it stop it with
the freaking hands the freaky as hell I
feel like like god damn oh I don't like
that I don't like that here a key
berries key there is key I got caught on
the fire what the hell huh where you go
yeah I got it
I need another key before I go into that
building hmm ok another key
another key nother ki-netic you are you
ha I portray a cancer drug it's ready
believe me he's my Barney okay oh no I
gotta go in and out what is that okay
that's something on the inside of the
house I gotta go in or I gotta unlock
this door and then is it gonna I got up
ah I'm not gonna be able to beat this
that's stupid hand it freaks me out
I don't like it I don't like it at all
uh hand oh that's a good idea I've never
I've never I've never come across
something like that before I'm really
freaky oh man the first time a copy
totally off guard that was like laughs I
thought it was a shadow on my screen or
something
ooh okay anyway let's get the second one
where are you
ah where is it there it is okay got it
okay let's get the let's get in there oh
man oh man uh yeah do not like this do
not like this I do not like this Sam I
am I do not like green eggs and ham get
in there get in get in get hello
samplings there's something wrong with
food booth Oh No ah hello I hand what
the hell I was at the end was that the
end I guess I was the end oh no I feel
like something I feel like I'm missing
something what I heard a key was there a
third key ah why
I'm running I'm running as fast as I can
run what the hell did I miss some I'm
Rossum ISM and this scrip Belu ah
prepare okay I'm done I'm done I'm done
I'm done
ha ha ha that can go to hell Oh creepy
alright so anyway thank you all so much
for watching you can check the
description for the link to this game
maybe there's something I miss at the
end something that were you to find out
so give it a try let me know what you
think so thank you again and as always I
will see you in the next video
ah
Wow